so let's let's get started with the next
prop so we have the privilege of having
Raluca SP she is one of the pioneers
like cryptosystems
PhD at MIT now she's effects whenever
here and she'll talk about the
centralized authorization frameworks for
transparency thank you and nice to see
you everyone so I'm going to tell you
about wave which is a system for
decentralized authorization from
transparency logs can you hear me well
okay great all right so this is going to
work with my students Michael and Sam as
well as as well as with Professor David
color and his students mustafa game
so this talk has two parts the first
I'll tell you about transparency logs
which I think are a very interesting
type of blockchain that combines the
qualities of the centralized security
with the performance of centralized
hosting and I find them very useful in
thinking about the architecting
classical security systems with the
centralized security so an example of
such a system is our platform wave which
replaces the classical access control
server where you put all your
permissions and you trust it with the
permissions with a decentralized
authorization framework where there
isn't any one server that you can attack
and this picture is from a real
deployment of our wave system on
hundreds of IOT devices which I'll
describe a bit later in the talk
so transparency blog logs are a type of
blockchain that have a decentralized
verification and centralized hosting so
in terms of the decentralized
verification the idea is that they give
some integrity guarantees that hold as
long as at least one of the parties is
honest you said any one specific party
can attack there's a system with
multiple parties and as long as one of
them is honest then you have integrity
guarantees at the same time is centrally
hosted so you can think of a big
provider like Google hosting this log
and because of this it has really high
throughput really good performance you
don't have to worry about proof of work
you don't have to worry about
duplicating the whole system state of
all these participants in the network
you don't even have to worry about
presenting consensus so it's very fast
but the whole point is that it's checked
it's verified in a decentralized manner
okay so you trust them with availability
the Google for example but you don't
trust with the integrity guarantees so
because you trust Google with
availability obviously Google can do
denial of service the the log right so
if Google won't they won't provide
service so this for example wouldn't be
fit for a cryptocurrency because you
can't just have your money disappear but
if you think about using this for
hosting certificates or access
permissions then maybe it's not such a
big problem because if Google denied
service and really their bigger problems
happening
and moreover this can also be insist
currently distributed across multiple
big provider so as long as one of them
is available then you're fine okay so
I'm not really concerned about this
downside at least for the kind of use
cases we are envisioning all right so
one very famous example of transparency
logs yeah question you don't want like
censorship or I mean there's a life
liveness in the sense that any honest
node could add to the log and yes so
we'll see in a moment so Google is the
one who gives availability right so any
node can send entries and Google can add
them if Google decides not to add them
it won't item but Google won't be able
to equivocate so we'll see in a moment
what guarantee it actually gives you
won't be able to show you two different
histories to two different people okay
but it can choose to not include an
entry in the log if it wants to
Oh so how many of you here know how
certificate transparency works okay one
person that's great two people okay
great
so I'm going to explain how it works and
I think it's very very interesting
so it's essentially type of blockchain
used for storing certificates like web
certificates and it addresses a 20 year
old problem with certificate authorities
what's the problem well the TS can be
compromised and issue fake certificates
so there's so many examples of that
including prominent ones like Verisign
which is you know one of the authorities
in the certificate space it should force
microsoft certificates and the
fundamental problem is that you can't
tell if a certificate is good or bad you
can't tell if it was produced by a party
while being compromised or not okay so
it's a really really tough problem and
people yeah define what you mean by the
world certificate precisely so what they
mean by certificates they refer to the
web certificates where for example when
you go to a website right TLS uses
certificates to authenticate that indeed
you're talking to the host you think
you're talking to so it basically is a
signature that binds a host name with a
public key so then you can use it for us
you know secure communication and so
these are integral the certificates are
integral to communicating on the web
whenever you have TLS and SSL you have
the green lock then you're using
certificates and the question is are the
certificate certificates trustworthy or
not okay because if they're compromised
and you think you're talking to Bank of
America but you're actually talking to
an attacker so in this case because
Microsoft certificates were compromised
then users were going to some attacker
site thinking it's actually Microsoft
when it wasn't
and so God has been really a
long-standing problem with many many
kinds of solutions but fundamentally the
problem remain that you can't really
tell if a certificate is compromised or
not
so certificate transparency is a real
system if actually used all the time you
are using it in your Chrome browser so
every certificate that you use in your
own Chrome browser has been validated by
city okay
chrome does not accept certificates that
have not been validated by City okay so
this is a very real deployment scenario
do I really know what is the public key
of this website I want to talk to to
some website do I know the public key of
that of the website I want to talk to so
here's a certificate this so it's
basically a signature let's say you want
to talk to Bank of America it's a
signature from an authority like
Verisign saying that Bank of America's
public key is this okay and your browser
trust Verisign because it has very signs
publicly hard-coded in the browser okay
so that's why you believe that does
certain you really believe that that is
the public key of Bank of America and
you start doing key exchange and secure
transferring security information okay
fake certificate is when Verisign was
compromised and tricked to sign for Bank
of America
wrong public key the public key of an
attacker that's a fake certificate
okay so let me tell you a bit of how a
certificate transparency works and our
system will be building on it later so
it has essentially two types of parties
the log server that stores the log of
certificates and then some monitors and
auditors that are checking the integrity
of the log server namely that it does
not equivocate and I'm going to conflate
the minders and auditors together let's
just call them auditors it's not that
important in distinction
all right so here's the guarantee that a
certificate transparency tries to give
at the high level that everyone sees the
same append-only log of certificates if
at least one auditor is not compromised
okay so everyone will see the same
history the same log of certificates
everyone in the world or not or not have
service from Google I mean they can also
be denied responses of course but if
they see something they're all going to
see the same log of certificates yeah
this is like exactly there can be
multiple providers each you know
providing a log let's just focus on just
one provider in the whole talk you just
look at one the situation repeats for
the others yeah so you have this log
provider restoring the log and then
you're gonna have this auditor parties
that are going to verify that the log
provider does not equivocate namely does
not provide two different logs to
different people so here is why this is
great and why this you know address is
the certificate the fake certificate
problem so Bank of America you know can
can register one of these certificates
can put them in the log for Bank of
America and then it can keep watching
the log to see what are all the
different certificates added to it okay
if it says okay so it's gonna check
every single certificate depend to the
log to make sure if it's for Bank of
America and it's really provided by Bank
of America okay so it's my trying its
own certificates
why because if there's a compromised
certificate authority that produces a
fake certificate for Bank of America and
appended append it into the log then
Bank of America is going to sit
it's going to see it immediately and
take action okay the point is that
what's really great fundamentally about
city is that you will be able to a user
will never be able to tell if a
certificate is good or not but they know
that the Bank of America would have seen
it okay it's bad okay so as soon as
someone registers a fake certificate for
Bank of America on the log then Bank of
America sees it catches it and can take
action and that action is outside of
City okay so now if a student fetches
the Bank of America certificate from the
log well they did again they don't know
if it's correct or not okay that's
that's a very difficult question to
answer but they know that Bank of
America saw it as well and is fine with
it
okay so implicitly it means that it's it
took it's a good certificate for Bank of
America okay so I think this was the
kind of the genius in this proposal is
now that is trying to verify whether
certificate is valid or not it's just
transparent saying that you know that
Bank of America is seeing the same
certificates for Bank of America and
they're okay with it that's does the
idea make sense okay
so someone needs to say this is Bank of
America's public key that he can we can
authenticate the logs so there is there
needs to be yes you have to assume that
Bank of America is monitoring the logs
the Bank of America is and Bank of
America's public no no necessarily no so
it's true that a lot provider has to
kind of do some cleaning
I mean desert can't just let everyone to
put certificates through Bank of America
it just creates like a you know junk
there but the point is at Bank of
American can see everything that's there
right and they can take action there's a
fig certificates recorded for Bank of
America
you don't have to trust there is
definitely that a little bit of a
verification of the Loki is doing but
doesn't have to be trusted because
here's what happens so that the some
lock provider can filter out attempts to
means offender certificate right saying
okay your bank of maker this reasonable
why because if they allow a fake
certificates to be added then there's
all this then Bank of Mecca will detect
it right and they have to take some much
more complicated actions but you don't
have to trust the law provider it is
very convenient though for them to check
hey does it make sense what's the
difference between let's say DNS DNS
takes a string of words and associates
an IP address okay
the certificate authority is essentially
association between
Bank of America and public key only that
- instead of DNS we have the we have
some very site that says okay Bank of
America this is the public key once I
have a public key we can
and everything but it's association
between public key and the name of Bank
of America is this the certificate Trice
is a signature right tries to be
certified by some Authority like varies
I'm the binding okay so it's not just
the binding like DNS it actually tries
to certify the binding okay
and ultimately yes you do so your
browser will probably look for certain
CAS into the log right at this trust
which was very sighing maybe a few other
CAS but ultimately if a fake certificate
makes it into the log for Bank of
America the Mac of America will detect
it okay that's the guarantee that
certificate transparency provides
yeah I already said it was outside of
the system but I'm just curious yeah
yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah yeah exactly so if someone
manages to somehow append a fake
certificate and then Bank of America
will detect it what do they do it will
stain the log it's it's you can issue it
a vocation list in the browser you can
issue all kinds of sort of things you
can contact that person you can take
legal action you know but still gonna
stain the log ok so it's complicated
what's preventing me to launch it now
shows that I can say that this is fake
this is fake all the time so I assume
I'm not Bank of Omega but I wanted to
prevent America to be updated so you can
claim to be back up on week and deny all
the updates to its so when Bank of
America finds a fake certificate they
can take out the bound action like a
legal action right and and you know in
legal action you prove that yourself in
whatever way to thank you for makin I
say it's fake fake you kind of say it's
fake you have to prove you know you have
to prove who you are you have to do all
this authentication there's already not
that occasion procedure pertaining
certificates in the first place right so
that exists but sometimes it gets
subverted through social engineering so
now we're just saying it's like okay
like in fact gets subverted we now at
least we'll find out about it so we can
go through the same thing
be more rigorous and like you know
something legally body but again I just
want to say this is outside of the city
system and I'm actually not really
interesting that at all what I'm
interested in is the guarantee that if
there's a fake certificate they're Bank
of America will find it will fit okay
that's the only property I'm interested
in the rest there's so many politics out
there was the legal procedure what do
you do what not I'm really not
interesting that okay there are great
questions about it it sounds to me
you're talking that certificate is about
binding penis is also about binding so
if there is a difference try to explain
to me why you are going why for example
your solution will not be a good
solution for DNS for example binding a
name of Bank of America with an IP
address the thing is that you don't
really need that security for DNS
because the TLS and the certificate are
two higher level so you don't really
need as for DNS for DNS is literally a
network function will just look up up up
you look up a public key right you don't
need a cryptographic binding based on
trust and based on you know people you
trust like you need for certificates DNS
is literally a systems function where
you're looking up you know some IP
address right and that's it you know and
then you have TLS on top but at a higher
level if you want I agree all right so
okay so we discuss this so now the
question is okay so now let's see how
the data structure looks like okay let
the structure actually very simple
it's a Merkel hash tree right so you
take the certificates and you just log
them based on time right so for example
certificate 3 was just added in the last
epic and then you just build the more
cohosh wrote on top of it okay so it's
just a is just the hash of certificate
zero is the hash of a and B and then
numerical hash reduce the hash of E and
F so it captures the whole tree you
should already know how Myrtle she is
working so how does the auditing work
well the log provider is going to send
in every epoch a signature of the Myrtle
hash root with a pokey number to the
auditors now the auditors are going to
start gossiping amongst each other to
make sure they're all getting the same
signature in every epoch okay if they're
getting two different signatures in the
same epic the log provider is
equivocating and is thrown away from the
system forever now there's more that
they have to do they have to check that
the pend only property is satisfied so
what they're going to do is in epic I
plus one it's going to ask the log
provider to probe to give the appended
certificates let's say that these were
appended in epic I plus one and it's
going to check that the pen property how
well it's going to take the old log
route which was this and then it's going
to hash these and hash together to
obtain the new log route okay so that's
how it's going to check that this log
was only appended okay all right and
there's another proof is the audit proof
in which you can check that the
certificate was indeed included in this
log okay so that's very simple you just
do merkel so for example if I want to
check the certificate 3 is included in
the log I'm just going to you know ask
from the log provider see right and I'm
going to ask e and then I can hash
things together again and check against
the Marco truth yeah are the leaves
basically the logs yeah so here's how
you check that it's append-only so in
epic I let's say this was what you had
in a book is with your log and this was
the merkel hash root and you had the
signature on it in that book i plus 1
this is the numerical hash truth because
you appended this the way you check its
append-only you make sure that things
weren't added only on the right how
you're asking the server for the hashes
of things that were ready on the right
and you're hashing up the yet
with the previous route on the right and
making sure you get the new route okay
so the communication overhead of check
yes yes yes absolutely the communication
over had yes it's indeed the size of the
increments a linear in the amount of
items added and logarithmic in the size
of the tree
and then this is how you check that the
certificate is in the log you just ask
for the miracle hash road yeah question
in the case you've added two items you
can provide yes absolutely I completely
agree with you absolutely agree with you
yeah in in this case when you added
these two values you just need to
provide this hash completely agree but
there are worse cases in which you
actually end up kind of providing more
of them constant definitely joerger is
making the path in the length of the
pattern right to be balanced right you
can always just be with the previous one
plus whatever you had well you want it
to be balanced so that the proof that
all this proof and the pass don't go too
much yeah yes you can do logarithmic now
the reason it's linear and so the
monitors do end up getting all of these
because they want to check if there's a
Bank of America certificate that had
appeared so yes but I agree just for the
sole purpose of this proof it can be
logarithmic great questions all right so
here's how you implement them in the
Bank of America example with you know
using the capabilities of City
underneath so Bank of America is gonna
be this auditor and monitor that's going
to constantly get the appended value
always and look at them is there a fake
certificate for Bank of America added
and it's going to check the proof of a
pen the pen sir is gonna do this proof
of consistency and so if a compromised
CI any time a pens a fake certificate
then then Bank of America is going to
notice it right it's going to say it at
the same time a user when they go to you
know in effect a certificate for Bank of
America did go into the audit proof and
make sure that indeed this certificate
is in the current merkel hash root
signed by the provider you know and it
gets that signature from for many
auditors right to make sure that there
isn't an equivocation
about that signature so this is how it
works any quick question before I go to
more interesting things browsers
basically when they they'll basically
query this on
like they would another note in which
the query right yeah there's a bit more
complication assistance sometimes it
gets proofs of merging as well at ignore
them in the simplified form is they're
going to basically ask for a certificate
from they're going to basically get a
certificate from Bank of America when
they visited you visit Bank of America
normally you get a certificate and you
need to check it in the city log so just
going to ask code for the audit proof or
it also the latest one in the log right
you're gonna check it against you don't
really check that because you make sure
that you know if there's a bad city some
bad city difficulty where they should
there's other mechanism that can do that
can be used to yeah so as long as a
certificate is not expired right and
it's in the log then you're happy you're
happy
original schedule schedule for doing it
in our service around the target and
just feeding him in all lower no because
that's the whole point that you prevent
equivocation with City the point is that
you prevent equivocation because the law
provided published the signature of the
merkel routine every epoch and everyone
makes sure it's consistent just feeds to
that sort of on lines of activity
happened attackers feeding to the
browser an old log information okay
there might have been an update to the
law that says I can't use this
certificate is being invalidated I see
and can and can deny service to the user
I mean there's some checks that they
probably do like the epic number should
be kind of recent within the current
time I'm sure they do some of these
checks they probably do that but you
know what the Packer cannot do is they
cannot trick the user in accepting a
certificate that is not in City that's
what the attacker cannot do and that's
the important property
all right actually we will get to their
location soon so just have a little bit
of patience okay so then uh so in
summary it offers transparency with the
centralized verification and high
throughput right because this is super
simple operation and the high throughput
is what's really cool if you want to
really techno classical security systems
in a decentralized way so speaking of
that our system wave is such an example
so in wave when you want to replace
servers that store access controlling
permissions we want them to be enforced
cryptographically so you don't have to
trust any one server so we are going to
store the permissions in a new
transparency log and I'll explain why we
need a new one
and the goal and the missions goal is to
replace mainstream authorization systems
like Active Directory or things like
this they shouldn't you shouldn't have
to trust a server to with your
permissions right the server could
delete the permissions could insert new
permissions could feed the permissions
so here is an example a motivating
example why traditional authorization
access control is not great and I really
like the IOT use case because I think
it's pretty thick so consider we have a
building owner that has many buildings
and he gives access to the tenant
company CEO to just the floor 3 their
startup company or floor 3 and then this
tenant gives access to its employees - I
know - the heating system light doors
lock so forth with the traditional
approach you have you know I have a
centralized server that stores all these
permissions what are problems with that
well first is a central point of attack
right an attacker can compromise it can
change permissions can read them second
it's actually really not clear who
should store the server because we are
having multiple trust domains here
there's the trust domain of the building
owner which delegates to his you know
the companies that rent from him and
then there's the trust domain within the
company okay which delegates to the
employees so if you put the server the
permissions server the building owner
then the building owner is going to see
all these delegations with independent
company and they're not supposed to see
that if you put this server instead that
tenant CEO right to store it and the
tenants here will see what you know to
what other companies the building owner
is delegating so there isn't really even
a natural place to to put a server like
this when you spend multiple domains
okay in some systems also like
transitive delegation basically what
that means that a Penant can own its own
delegate a subset of the permissions
okay so these are some traditional
systems for access control that are
pretty famous and that in that provide
transitive delegation the main problem
they have is that they don't they they
have a central authority that they trust
they trust the server to store this you
know store permission information and
second is that they actually get to see
to see permissions right so that's the
route see what the permissions are and
they are very they can be very private
right it's really fine grained about
what you have access to where you live
and what floor you work on and so forth
so in comparison our system waive avoid
central authority and protects
permissions in the public in a public
transparency lock while also providing
transitive delegation so to make this
happen there's actually a number of
challenges first is what kind of
blockchain do we need to store the
permissions well it turns out that
classical blockchain like if the realm
are not scalable enough and transparency
looks like certificate transparency as
you already discovered don't support a
location so we came up with a new
transparency loaf of the UL diem
transparency lock which I will describe
and then the question is okay so now
you're putting permissions on a public
block chain and everyone can see them
okay so how can you encrypt them and
turns out to be very difficult to you
can't just use public key encryption
because it's too coarse-grained okay
people are supposed to delegate things
and then delegate to others and others
now there's when you give access to
someone you don't know to whom they're
gonna delegate and while they're gonna
be like okay so we have protocol called
reverse discoverable encryption which
allows us to encrypt the permissions but
have
people be able to discover their the
permissions that are relevant to them
but not discover permissions relevant to
others
all right so in the rest of the talk I
will focus on mostly on the transparency
log in interest of time but to
understand how it works I'm just going
to introduce some background on just how
our in authorization model works ok so
first a bit of background and then we're
going to talk about the transparency log
and at the high level how the encryption
works so we represent access control as
the graph okay which is a model that
already existed in from 96 start in
spooky so it's a graph instead of an
access control list table because the
graph naturally represents a transitive
delegation right so who gave access to
art and so forth so we have entities
participant in the system that are
identified by public keys exactly like
in a cryptocurrency so this is a very
see it's like a situation and then we
grant permissions so edges represent
permissions and we grant permissions by
signing okay to the permission Razak was
granted similarly to when you pay when
you make a transaction you know in a
cryptocurrency okay so for example here
the building owner is signing that is
giving access to floor 3 to the seal and
there's going to be other stuff that's
important
okay and then the CEO is going to sign
that they give access to the heating
system to employee one
okay so in this sense it parallels the
crypto currency trend transactions now
how does an employee prove to the door
lock that he has permission to it well
the proof is the pass okay is this path
from the owner of the door which is the
building owner for which you can assume
that the door has the publicly
hard-coded right it's this path of
signatures okay and it gives access to
what to the intersection of the
resources okay so this path of
signatures gives access to the doors of
floor three okay to the employee it
doesn't give access to all of those
three it's an intersection right
okay so that's pretty simple and so this
forms a global graph where you can put
everyone's imagine everyone's
permissions of the global graph and you
can have many different owners so it's
decentralized because you know every
single owner with their own resources or
you know have some resources in this
graph and other owners have other
resources so it's really decentralized
based on how people own things okay and
it's important that different
participants will only see portions of
the graph is the graph model clear
alright great so now that we understood
the graph model I can explain how we
actually store this graph and what we
need from a transparency log to be able
to store a graph like this and look like
a graph like this and then I'm going to
explain a very very high level how we do
this reverse discoverable encryption
okay so our transparency log is called u
LD m which stands for unequivocal log
derived map I will explain the name and
it's meant to store encrypted
permissions for now assume they're not
gonna be encrypted we're gonna encrypt
them later and revocations
okay and but i want to say that it's
really applicable beyond storing
permissions we are extending certificate
transparency with revocation so it's
it's useful for you know any scenarios
where you want these basic properties
all right so first what do we need from
this log okay well this centralized
Security's before we wanna what I mean
by that is the same thing that you know
the log provider cannot equivocate okay
so you don't have to trust any one
server for that yet the built-in
append-only again then we also need
efficient proofs of existence okay so if
it efficiently check that something
exists like a permission exists in the
log but then I also want efficient
proofs of non-existence any ideas why
why do I want deficient put some on I
guess yeah
exactly exactly you wanna prove that you
haven't been revoked right so you you I
mean you could you can also prove you
were evoke it's just not very you know
you want to prove you were revoked when
you access for when you want to do some
resources yeah and I still want to high
performance why I don't wanna make this
thing slower so okay so yeah we append
only in this context of authorizations
is it visit the current state the best
like you know so I definitely don't want
permissions to be thrown away
and discarded right and that's that's
one easy way to make sure that
but the terminal a discarded is like
user error right like you know I what
make sure that a lot provider is not
deleting my access or something or is
not deleting a revocation because
they're colluding with the revoke user
yeah yeah so actually yeah anyways
initially we're looking at using an
earlier system but you know it has many
issues like so we're using a classical
blockchain but it has many issues it's
yeah you can imprint upon implement all
the security aspects but it's not
efficient then you can think of
certificate transparency but certificate
authority does not have efficient proofs
of non-existence and if you think about
it it is a little bit at odds with the
immutability and append-only property
right because if I want to show it's
append on in an append based on time but
then how am I gonna efficiently show
that the value doesn't exist right the
efficiently show that the value doesn't
exist that kind of data structure sorted
by value so argue ldm need a
structurally consult this property and
offers efficient proofs of non-existence
on top of the properties of certificate
transparency
so we'll incite well the insight is kind
of what the name says we are going to
derive a map from a log so the map is
going to be used to prove non-existence
or existence right because maps are
dictionaries and you can map based on
value you can usually and we're gonna
drive them from a log which we're gonna
use to prove the append-only
proper game okay in terms of overall
parties it's very similar to certificate
transparency we have a log provider
storing the log we have clients that can
append or read and we have auditors that
verify ok so now let's see how the data
structure or the log provider looks like
the first part is like in certificate
transparency we have an operation log
where we log operations in know as they
show up to the right depend only each
operation is going to be a tiene value
pair and they're always going to be
appended on the right like in
certificate transparency so these log
grows by time and is sorted by time so
it's exactly City here now here's where
the differences come in we have actually
three layers of data structures so what
happens that we also maintain an object
map the object map is key to value ok
it's actually sorted based on the hash
of the key they sorted based on the hash
of the key and it contains all the keys
in the system so the to map the map and
the log they both contain the same data
values just sorted differently and
whenever you you know in the phonetic
islets you append these values then
you're gonna have to insert them in the
in the object map and then we take the
root of the object map and keep it in a
hash chain like like a block chain okay
so basically what we have in each block
is we have the hashes for an epoch and
so for example here
so here we just have you know the epic
number than the hash of the previous
because this is a hash chain and we have
a hash of the object map looped and the
hash of the operation Law Group okay so
we have the hashes of the two trees in
the in the hash chain and this is what
the log provider is going to sign and
give two auditors okay so it's good when
low provider provides one of these
signatures in a netbook it took a
snapshot of the state of the operation
log and object map okay and it includes
the hash of the previous block so it
includes the whole history of the
snapshots of the two logs okay so one
single signature has a whole history of
all the state of the two trees in every
single epoch so what did the auditors do
first they need to check they're getting
the same signature because you know in a
netbook should only get one signature
from the law provider the low providers
should not equivocate and provide
different ones then it also has to check
that the operation log in the object map
are computed correctly so for the object
law for the operation log is just gonna
check append on in the same ways for
certificate transparency okay but then
is going to take those appended items
and insert them into the object map well
actually is going to ask the server for
proof that they were inserted in the
correct way okay so how do you do that
well for every single value that was
appended you as the server for merkel
hash proof that it was inserted in the
correct place and remember that things
are sorted by the hash so you can tell
was the correct place how let's say I
have to insert the key between 0 & 1
okay I'm going to first tell the server
okay I mean to insert this key so tell
me the proof of the enclosing rage okay
what is the tightest enclosing range so
to me they are in the tree proof to me
they're in the tree by using the regular
merkel proof okay
against the root of the tree from the
previous book once you establish this is
the correct range you you basically do
the inserting here
okay and then you recompute the whole
merkel hash to check is the one from the
new epic this is a very high level cuz
there's a ton of technicality yeah yeah
you can do rotations by always proving
them with the Merkel route against the
Warka route
so you duel in your work in every single
dependent operation yes
the server does that work and then the
auditors have to prove just the Merkel
Road has to prove them have to check the
Merkel paths
yeah
the rehashing is is not I mean it's not
a bottleneck for us I mean it's
definitely more scalable and a regular
blockchain for example
and the nice thing is that you don't
work with it actual so the auditors
never work with the actual data they
just work with the hashes and check them
you can check so many hashes you can
check a lot
but if I were to us if you were to ask
me what is you know if you increase and
increase and increase increased scale
but what point which is the point at
would become first heaviest I would say
it's the this part for the auditors
so it's append-only see you know it
depend only yeah you don't you just
expire so they're not useful but it's a
very good point you know if because if
you worry about the scale right then one
of the scale just grows logarithmically
but sure it grows forever yes but but
the depth the depths only girls will
grow as McCully and all the work of
crooks oh but I'm not been hatching the
whole thing I'm never washing the whole
thing so this is a lot of technicality
in how you do this kind of miracle
updates I'm never in hashing the whole
thing so let's say I just inserted
something in here okay this this is a
binary search tree maybe it caused a
small local rotation okay with the
amount of items I touched is logarithmic
by the guarantees of the binary search
tree coach like for example in that
example doesn't k1 now to move to like
the other side of the tree so imagine an
AVL tree let's say or something or a
binary search tree right am I gonna have
to when you put something in here am I
gonna have to do like rotation this is
balanced but it's not perfectly balanced
right it's not perfect it's balanced but
not perfect like you can have a like a
level twice as large as the other but
not that much exactly yeah so you can
have some leaves you know some some sub
trees a little bit unbalanced but it's
still balanced within a factor so it's
like an AVL tree or a red-black tree
they're all balanced trees and
deterministic trees yeah but if it were
perfect to be like this I agree include
yeah how does this compare to the
extended certificate transparency paper
which is that the V LBL or which which
one do you mean paper called extended
certificate transparency that had the
same like you'd have a log of operations
and then you have a tree that's there is
a very short line so if it the one you
were referred to there's a very short
like a sketch somewhere I think there
was on a Twitter people post and it
wasn't clear how they do doesn't clear
how they do the auditing they didn't
even describe it it wasn't clear how
they do the also the matching and the
merge promises and all of this so there
many things weren't clear that we look
at the implementation it wasn't really
clear there was definitely a sketch it's
an attempt of doing this but it's not an
actual paper so we look at it we can
really understand the source code
doesn't really have it so we are maybe
an academic approach trying to do the
same thing
all right so now we can see how you can
prove existence right so you can prove
existence easily against this object map
right because I can if I want to check
that value using the Merkle tree for the
object but I just tell the server hey
give me the you know give me the
authentication pass and I can check it
you can also see how I can prove
non-existence okay the way I prove
non-existence is I tell the server hey
prove to me that this value doesn't
exist and the server has to give you
again the most enclosing interval for
where that value would have gone in okay
and give you the merkel pass that you
can check and use the current signature
but know that you can also check where
these values are in the tree why because
the paths are like left right right now
you know so you can tell that two values
really come after each other in the
miracle tree okay so you can really
check that nothing is in the middle
between them is it clear it takes a bit
of it just to be the finality with
Merkel trees with the point is that
there is nothing in there so the only
the object map for the proof of not
existence existence you can use the
operation log problem
yes but even then even then it might be
less efficient because let's say
appended the million values in the last
step but then I have to scan those
million values to check existence
right so it's not going to be
logarithmic guarantees for the proof of
existence I mean can't you just point to
some node and show the path from that
operation to the oh sorry so yes
absolutely yes it's lagging certificate
transparency yes yes you're right yeah
exactly I see
you cannot prove existence here as well
yeah is it that the object map telling
if for example I have a million
operations onto the same K zero the
object map actually only has one case
you're the latest case here or are this
would ever think we could ever think we
don't lose anything yeah yeah and
definitely our I mean as I said our main
contribution top of city is the proof of
non-existence
all right I understand you have a look
the look isn't over okay if the log
there is a certificate that says I as
far as you and you authorize there's
some others and there is a whole tree
behind you authorization okay then i
evoke there is now a lot of things that
we need to revoke to others let's talk
about a vocation right now this is
sitting in a in in a line in there in
the log in the log it's a line that's
like Union fight this is Union fighter
now I go and I have American today and I
want to think of a miracle tree as a
two-slit tree or whatever that I want to
all these things were seeking them in a
miracle tree but in some order
I can now hush them and get them and
find ya know when I D otherwise you
somehow somebody well how do we go now
to the military and we essentially
eliminate absolutely let's talk about a
vocation right now this is the next step
talking about a vocation so this okay
this is what this laser can do this
especially lot individual is level a
revocation so let me show let's let's
take this the concrete example the CEO
gave access to alleys to the lock okay
and now Alex wants to go to the lock and
say hey I have access because the seal
look I have this thing sure from the CEO
I have access so let me knock unlock you
but then the lock says what if you were
revoked you know you need to prove to me
that you were not revoked and it's so
how does the lock know that the Alice
Alice's access was not revoked in the
meantime it's actually not as simple as
just throwing a proof of non-existence
it's a little bit tricky okay so let's
look at it obviously I don't wanna
scandal all just too much work so let's
try to use proof of non-existence it's a
little bit tricky so first attempt the
CEO can append to the log this operation
revoke cig okay so revoke this signature
append it into the transparency log
okay and then Alice provides the proof
that this revocation so provides a proof
to the locker the revocation revoke for
this signature does not exist no
transparency log ok uses the proof of
non-existence the the lock is say okay
the CEO clearly didn't revoke it
it's convinced of that but what is what
is the problem though there's a problem
here
can someone say we want now to prevent
that she will four vans forth she
cameras don't be able to provide because
he's revoke in this in the she provides
a proof that they were okay so let me
explain this properly okay let me
explain this again so the CEO can if the
CEO wants to revoke right you can append
revoke a signature to the log okay now
as is the CEO did not revoke Alice then
she can prove the non-existence of this
binding she can always give an old proof
like before the revoke was there but are
you in the mob can always get the latest
know has them latest at book number and
the latest signature okay let's assume
now that's a great point that simplicity
let's assume that the log has the lock
has the latest signature right for the
current epoch and let's assume that the
CEO did not be vocalists we actually
don't revoke a list so she is able to
provide approve the revocation does not
exist using the proof of non-existence
this is this is all fine the Securities
is fine here in terms of her you know
revocation by the lock or not but
there's some other form via
the revocation yes let's make it unique
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
take exactly this signature and all
we're gonna do is gonna put the word
revoke in front of it and this signature
I'm gonna throw that in a transparency
log yeah
yeah yeah so notices you in general
anyone can revoke any permission right
because all that it takes all that it
takes to revoke someone's permission is
to start putting the transparency log a
message revoke comma that permission
right anyone can do it there's no scent
occasion here at the signature that the
CEO actually intended to revoke this
oh so this is a signature from so this
is the original permission and all of
this yo does is it adds revoke and the
signature in a transparency log
there's no it doesn't stop in this
scheme it doesn't sign it I thought if I
can submit my perm if I can use the
malleability to grant myself
there's no ability here this is a
regular as a signature especially a
portable yeah well I talked about little
prevents to inclusion of wrong
statements there was orbiter checking
that that's in certificate transparency
but in there how would all Eater know
whether some permission is accepted or
not right yeah can we see your modified
later ization so change is mine sure I
mean the CEO can grant you permissions
for anything that he has access to but
let me clarify this like this so this
this was still a straw man in which all
I it takes to revoke someone is to say
we work with that with the permission
they had okay so this is obviously
anyone can just take someone's
permission and say revoke and then
revoke them right so there's no this is
silly so let's just fix this in a very
straightforward way that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe I'll figure the slice to
make that more clear the thing was just
the original think okay maybe I'll just
give it a notation we just original
thing and you live on the res you'll see
the Stroman is helpful because it was
working in in terms of if you were
revoked then the lock wouldn't give you
access
okay but it would be denial of service
by someone okay so this one here's what
happens with this one the your signs
okay this is permission when society's
revocation when you put it in the log
but there's a video problem here so I
goes to the lock and she says hey I have
access and the log says prove to me that
how can she possibly do that
what does she give a distinction of
non-existence for right so if she wasn't
revoked
she wasn't revoked by the CEO this
signature was never put in the log she
doesn't know what his signature is it's
unforgeable so she cannot give a proof
of non-existence for something that she
doesn't know what it is because she knew
she needs to say hey lo provider being a
pro forma existence for this value right
but she doesn't know what the value is
because the signature doesn't exist
of the log the log itself is a computer
it can go and check things they look the
log is an entity they just they just if
you works if you get something you do or
go and check this the lock has distinct
check for the current epoch of you know
from the lock provider well that's it it
doesn't go anywhere ok so that she has
access and that she hasn't been revoked
and she has the current signature ok
from the log provider in the current
epoch ok so I'm trying to go here
through some straw man ok which are
which are not working just to kind of
build it up and so now because the CEO
has to sign or revoke statement it's no
longer the case that anyone can revoke
you ok
so that's that's fixed but there's a sub
table the problem is that Alice would
like to give a proof of non-existence
that this value does not exist in the
log but since this funny doesn't exist
in luck she doesn't know what the value
is the signature is unforgeable moreover
signature is also being randomized so
why don't you just try to find Annie
Walker signature part and then use this
you later on for pigs no instances for
the de volcán signature
they told blood will check whether
there's a sign the same Center as well
okay okay
the beginning let's work through this
okay you can pour evoke a spinny chair
huh but in order to prevent the denial
service attack once the proper existence
is it's a great great attempt to but
here's here's the problem the problem is
that and I like interactive things but
the promise that okay so the locus is
that is someone put someone was mean
malicious could revoke and signature on
though we don't because it's a
general-purpose lock we didn't want to
make it but it's true if you if the lock
provider would only accept right leave
box at our company in the biasing so we
can fix it in a very simple way
now here's the way actually quite simple
signature for the CEO includes the seal
is gonna flip it's gonna take a random
value s it's going to the hash for the s
into the signature it's a secret random
value only the CEO knows it okay when
the CEO wants to when the Tia wants to
revoke alice is going to put this value
s because only the CEO knows s okay he's
going to put s into the you know into
the transparency log
so therefore the operation map will
contain a Java striker distorted by the
hash of s the operation map is sorted by
the hash of F okay so now all that Alice
has to prove to the lock is that the
proof of non-existence for H of s she
has to propose an existence or for each
other that's it it's pretty simple but
it takes a few iterations to get to it
okay so the whole idea is that polling
you just
sure you can it could be a harsh or
deterministic signature that only does
still only this year would know a bigot
unforgeable
I got it Sudan you don't have to have
this fake yeah yeah you can implement it
yeah I shouldn't hear a correctness
constraint on the construction of the
welcome you said you were going to do
values in the second Treaty of hashed
believes is essentially a correctness
construction construction of the wall
providers said you wanted to avoid that
I think you can of course you know the
data structure has to be correct you can
still add things to the log but if it's
not properly formed it's going to be
ignored it's important here that the
hash function is the same that is yes
absolutely for the operation log yeah
yes that is the trick that is the trick
that the hash function is the same as
the hash function although over there
over the map rights of the operation
matter between the CEO and Alice there
is the department head revoke the
department yeah
I don't want Ellis to go to the log
because I saw her for sure yeah for sure
Ellis it's so assertion is for the
department so remember that the proof of
access is the path of signatures from
the owner of the resource so if she gets
revoked any one of them she won't be
able to show the whole path
she won't have access so did look looks
at all paths yeah I mentioned that
before yeah so I think I turn another
subtle point which is what happens if
the CEO that person gets revoked then
how what prevents them from actually
doing replications on Alice that are
invalid gets revoked so basically let's
say there's the building owner right and
gave access to the CEO to the ah you
want you want it in here yeah so yes
there's gonna be there's gonna be a
thing to for every edge and both I just
have to be proved that I can they have a
board we have to reissue like as you
redo your work chart it's like a key if
you chop off the top layer your org
chart then presumably everybody needs a
new manager as long as there's a path
that still valid a story the fact that
hasn't been revoked will get access
right a path from the resource owner
that hasn't been revoked you still get
access a path that contains the the
local axis you see yeah
you need to give them access in some
other way or you can shoot that others
people may be still I mean yeah I mean
if you to eliminate the whole subtree so
this is Davidson yeah if you and your
name is transitive for you expensive to
look axis its axis but if you go to axis
from someone else in your fine alright
so this gave you a sense of the yo Geum
Ran's parity log right and how we
basically add revocation to certificate
transparency and I have very little a
few minutes left actually a little bit
negative time so I mean just gonna very
high-level just mention what's going on
here so this is just the grass of access
right and this HVAC controller you know
it has access to floor three as you can
see there's the pass of floor three from
the building owner so what we want is we
want to put all these permissions
encrypted in the transparency log right
because it's public so we need to
encrypt them so the people not everyone
sees them right but they have to be
included in such a way that each back
controller can decrypt the green arrows
and cannot decrypt the red arrows so you
can only decrypt the all path
permissions that are intersecting and
cannot decrypt own path that is not
intersecting so for floor 4 since it
doesn't actually get access to to be
able to decrypt and also he should be
able to decrypt the Jannah first
permissions and anyways there's like all
kinds of strohman so yeah so I mean the
high level link of the permissions on
each permission we call this secret that
allows you to decrypt upstream
permissions and there's all kind of like
Stroman we could go through that I
really find why public key encryption is
insufficient you can either the crypt
you know way more like even things that
are floor for you you can just not be
able to decrypt things so it's it's
really course I'm not going to go
through it but the point is that public
key encryption is
is the course for this purpose the
reason is that the encryption has to
take into account what the permission is
so when we include the permission the
key inside the encryption should depend
on the apps you know should depend on
what the permission is so that it
unlocks upstream permissions that are
intersecting with it ok and so anyways
you can look in the paper we have a
scheme that uses an inter-basin
encryption wildcard identity based
encryption that is able to narrow down
the visibility of you know every node in
the system to own pass and intersecting
ok so I'm just gonna conclude um really
fast so we implemented away with the
real system it's open source it's
implemented in going c++ we deployed it
as well actually we operated it for two
years now and we deployed in on over 230
devices like thermostats HVAC
controllers motion sensors so this is
the permission graph of our deployment
so the thicker nodes are owners of
resources and the smaller nodes are no
that get access so you can see the edges
are just permissions so that's been
really fun you know working with real
system operating it for it you know two
years and we learned a lot sort of the
performance I'm just gonna brush really
fast through the graph changing
operations are in order of milliseconds
which we think by you know what you can
notice from a UI standpoint is it's you
know it's fast and you know this is a
graph of showing how long it takes to
you know to build the proof you know
again on the order of tens of
milliseconds and to verify it and at
least in our deployment the average
proof length so is a four with four so
therefore delegation's was the average
proof length
okay so in conclusion wave is a
decentralized operation system yeah very
very very good very good point very good
point so many IOT device so in in many
cases we have agents we call them wave
agents I didn't miss there's a whole you
know this system has a lot of systems
building behind it beyond what I
explained and many of these devices work
with agents so they just have a secure
communication for an agent and the agent
is able to implement things like wave
that least you don't change how to
device in at least in cases like
raspberry PI's then utility change
because it's its universities and
campuses in California so it's mostly
California yeah 20 buildings across
different UC campuses so we have a bunch
of scalability you know experimenting in
the paper and yes the hope is to scale
like certificate transparency to the
globe I'm not gonna make a statement
that we do necessarily do that but
that's that's the hope in knowing a lot
of the overheads are just logarithmic so
and we have some emulations and
simulations for a larger scale but I'm
not gonna just say these scales to the
globe but that's the that's the hope
right that's the intention with the
design okay
so wave is a decentralized Authority
system that uses cryptographically
enforced and graphics authorization
stores the graph in a new transparency
love your DM and include SATA stations
to hide the graph instead of just using
a server that's trusted to store all
permissions and you know the hope with
this is to replace traditional
authorization system thank you thank you
very much for an interaction with lots
of fun
ix yeah